(soft music)
- [Narrator] Seaweed
is a common ingredient
in Japanese cuisine.
But, there's unique type
growing in the Pacific Ocean.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Seventy miles off
the coast of mainland Japan
is the small island of Okinawa.
Home to one of the most
unusual farming methods
in the world.
- [Narrator] Mr. Oshiro comes
from a seafaring family.
And today, he's one of the
farmers growing mozuku,
a special seaweed only
grown in these waters.
- [Narrator] Each fall,
a web of nets are laced
with mozuku seedlings on land.
Then, Mr. Oshiro and his
son lay the nets in rows
in the shallow water.
This ingenious system allows
the mozuku to grow sustainably
by not creating additional waste.
And when the time is
right, it is harvested
with two boats and their giant vacuum.
(engine starts)
- [Narrator] The day’s harvest
is then taken to his factory
where it's cleaned, weighed and processed.
Then, it's off to the markets
to sell his underwater treasure.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Mozuku is in high demand.
It's packed with nutrients,
so many people eat it
for a health boost.
But, that wasn't always the case.
(piano music)
- [Narrator] In recent years,
Mr. Oshiro has seen a change in the ocean.
So the future of his mozuku is uncertain.
- [Narrator] Despite the challenges,
Mr. Oshiro's dedication proves this work
is more than just a day job.
For him, it's about
maintaining a family tradition
and passing on his father's
respect for the sea.